how's it going res my name is Pharma and
welcome to a brand new horror game this
one is called the Train that's it's a
Russian horror game from what I heard
this game is very pretty and looks kind
of nice yeah it looks nice
flicks legit that's cool I'm gonna train
surprisingly enough I kind of want to
play this game with the oculus but I
don't have to play every game on the
oculus I don't know sometimes it's nice
with the girl screen you know why is
there no one else on this damn train
who's leaving these bottles around okay
well this is creepy okay we are
officially fine that's okay let's keep
going on the train
Jules this feels more like a metro than
a train out of them there's a key there
son of a [ __ ] okay we need to find
something a bottle of course no hello
let's get memory what's that there are
some stuff in a few Oh
[Music]
is there anything else okay let's just
let's just use the conveniently placed
lockpick okay
we have a lockpick I also notice you can
close your eyes in the game kind of
similar to I don't remember the name for
some reason I'll come to me don't worry
hi everyone I was gone by the [ __ ] are
we anyway Jase whoa whoa
you stay away I'm not gonna get killed
by a man can I ride you know
can i what is that whoa whoa [ __ ]
balls man okay I have a ball best game
ever oh how do I bounce it what are you
doing
okay I'm keeping this ball aah balls no
no leave me but aah
god damn it we're back here now okay
ball come here
Bengt Bank 2002 and Bank the [ __ ] am i a
little kid I feel like I'm sure
ah mom irska ba busca hiiii it's not our
Russian people talk oh that's adorable
what else do we got uh no child's happy
it's a part of a few surprises ice cream
in the hot summer day a present under
the Christmas tree in New Year's but
nothing of this can substitute mothers
and fathers laughs I like that
that's very Kim it's true except I'm
sweet as her new ride
yeah okay
I can't write it now hello truck what do
you know oh the door is of what banked
Bank what is happening my memory is
coming back to me okay
well that's normal I'm sure that happens
to you too it's fine don't worry about
now big deal Oh
pretty sure I heard a baby the [ __ ] is
with all these shh-shh you creep it Pony
what I've told you about riding trains
god damn you pony Oh what the [ __ ] are
you doing son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
dreaming it did I die
what happened more toys pony why didn't
you warn me I'm sorry ped well start it
hey little girl watch it don't scream at
me hug hug
what why do we you one minute I don't
don't look at me like that okay oh you
want the ball oh you are bangs all right
of course it's obvious don't kill me
okay I'm coming I'm coming to get your
ball girl coming to get jump off I'm
coming to get your bugger I'm coming to
get your ball go it's coming - hey Bo
hey blue ball I got the ball yeah
best game huh don't you dare laugh like
that
you creepy [ __ ] I don't like to spanked
I know you're scared banked but it's
gonna be fine it's gonna be okay all
right
but parents we should kill him no this
is not that game high pony this is the
game where we get balls to women best
game ever
here you go Little Miss just don't kill
me okay what the I gave you that ball
what the [ __ ] oh my bad my bad you take
the ball just Hey throw it to me because
I would
I'm sorry bank had it all no Bank is
gone forever
oh no brother I can't believe we just
gave him up like that
ah Sh more really okay everyone calm Dov
why did I just told you what the [ __ ] is
going on here I don't know what happened
but I but oh okay I get it I get it
sorry my bad I'm stupid [ __ ] kids man
okay here we go
man that [ __ ] nail that fish later
noobs back better lock the doors okay
ah guitar yay hey it's amber Paoli
Oh what the [ __ ] always cheerful and
then eh
okay
well me and Burke are gonna have a
little talk aren't we I guess I can lock
with a key I don't I don't know I I mean
I'm sure someone is lucky to born be
born strong proud Falcon eat the flesh
meat and someone were born in a hole and
he's carrying we're gonna check in here
they've got some to look cool no oh it
did work okay well [ __ ] locking doors
you don't even have to lock the door oh
oh we're back we're back so apparently
my our decisions are we're a little
older now yeah we're living through our
life and we can make decisions I'll go
in here oh okay well this is a nice
neighborhood I guess I was being saved
okay
Hey oh there's actual people hey how you
doin Ruby Ruby it's me Reuben you have a
fine ass man oh excuse me
hey what's your name Leonard well
Leonard you look like a vampire hey not
those gay ass Twilight vampires the cool
ones Oh mamacita excuse me is this seat
taken
haha this is your boy oh sorry I don't I
don't want to
I don't money I don't want to go there
I'm not ready for that [ __ ] don't care
how hot you what that [ __ ] who you
looking at
nice tits still oh they're all looking
at me aren't there that is the [ __ ]
creepy [ __ ] I'm sorry I can't win this
party where you had a great time I
should not have interrupted you guys you
know what I'm just gonna let you go do
whatever you want
we're fine okay that's this [ __ ] Oh
what the [ __ ] are you this match man
fantasy don't look at them whoa they
don't exist
they don't XS we don't accept that our
[Laughter]
oh they don't whoa what the [ __ ] cop
they don't like this no no you don't
exist you don't exist you don't [ __ ]
XS tits on drill kiss on drill ah okay
okay four five
hey nice boobs you don't exist you don't
exist you don't exert a your own exec
you don't exist nice dick okay this is
so [ __ ] creepy what do you want from
me mannequins ah don't you - Danny mom
okay you're standing in my way sorry
god damn
alright brother that was really fun I'm
looking forward to do part two leave a
like if you want it and I'll try to
upload it as soon as possible subscribe
to come talk to me I'm doing my job
this guy Cole Road today I'll seen the
next a awesome view
[Music]